Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
So, die Sendung geht erst los, wenn du mir beweisen kannst, dass du ein Mensch bist.
Ich beweise nicht, also bin ich.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 503 vom, was haben wir denn heute? 13.
Oktober 2024 ist immer noch das Jahr.
Genau und da sind wir wieder. Euer Rohrschachttest für Nachrichtenverarbeitung sozusagen.
Ihr müsst dann da drauf schauen, was wir hier so von uns geben oder euch das
anhören und dann erwarten wir irgendeine Reaktion.
Die messen wir über einen magischen Rückkanal, den wir installiert haben,
geheim, in eurem Podcast-Client, haben wir reingehackt und dann machen wir uns
unsere Gedanken über euch.
So wird das sein, Tim. So wird das sein.
Du meinst, wenn ich das sage, dann muss das so sein?
Dann muss das so sein, ja.
Ja, mit der Erkennung von Menschen ist es ja ein bisschen schwierig geworden.
Mark-Uwe Kling hatte das, glaube ich, in Quality Land, ich weiß gar nicht,
ob es in 1 oder 2 war, schon vorhergesehen, dass irgendwann, also Captures,
also weißt du eigentlich die genaue Abkürzung, wofür Capture steht?
Ich bin schon dabei.
Das war bei der DEF CON dieses Jahr Frage.
Beim Hacker Jeopardy. Der Completely
Automated Public Touring Test to tell Computers and Humans apart.
Also der automatische öffentliche Touring Test zur Trennung von Menschen und Computern.
Also zur Unterscheidung.
Zur Unterscheidung. Und der eben, der am Ende die Antwort, die Frage beantworten
soll, bist du denn ein Roboter beziehungsweise Computer oder nicht?
Und genau, im Buch Quality Land beschreibt Marc-Uwe Kling auch genau das,
erklärt auch diese Abkürzung da, das habe ich glaube ich daher auch gelernt.
und sagt dann, dass aber irgendwann die Captures so schwierig wurden,
dass man die nur noch mit KI lösen konnte.
Und dass sie deshalb andersrum funktionieren, nämlich dadurch,
dass Menschen sie nicht mehr gelöst kriegen.
Und dieser Moment ist jetzt eingetreten, weil inzwischen getrainierte KIs Captures
besser lösen als Menschen.
Es war auch schon immer so ein bisschen albern. Ich meine, wer weiß denn schon,
wie amerikanische Wasserhydranten aussehen? Rot.
Das lernt man, hast du kein Internet oder was?
Aber das ist immer so ein Amerika-Zentrismus, dass sie immer davon ausgehen,
dass so ihre Infrastruktur auch überall sonst auf der Welt genauso aussehen.
Also da sind sie sicherlich nicht die einzigen.
Naja, also deutsche Hydranten hätten sich einfach nicht geeignet, ne?
Ja, aber ich meine.
Aber das wäre auf jeden Fall mal. Da musst du langsam mal eine KG trainieren.
Da hat der Amerikaner auf jeden Fall Probleme. Da hast du sozusagen so ein Capture-Totel,
Americans and Germans apart.
Ne, dann siehst du halt diese, kennst du doch diese weißen Schilder,
wo dann steht, wo der Hydrant ist? Die weißen Schilder mit dem roten Rand, ne?
Und dann hast du nämlich so ein Schild im Bild und dann musst du aber zeigen,
wo der Hydrant ist. Da steht ja auf dem Schild, drei Meter in die eine,
drei Meter in die andere Richtung.
Und dann musst du nämlich ein anderes Feld antippen.
Das kannst du nur noch mit, das kann nur noch KI. Das kann nur noch KI.
Naja, auf jeden Fall, das ist dann ein Kaptgar. Kaptgar.
Okay.
Ja, der Turing-Test, um halt Deutsche und Amerikaner auseinanderzuhalten.
Ist das ein Hydrant oder nicht?
Ich brauche einen Thuring-Test, um Thüringen, Sachsen,
ja, und wie heißt, sag mal noch ein paar neue Bundesländer, also Thüringen, Sachsen, Anhalt.
Brandenburg, Berlin, ja, heile Berlin, nicht ganz so neu.
Gibt es nicht noch einen?
Ne.
Nur fünf?
Ja, fünf neue Länder, FNL. Fünf neue Bundesländer.
Suddenly it all makes sense.
Das ist eigentlich ganz einfach. Normalerweise, ich kann die auch ganz gut auseinanderhalten.
Ich kenne ja auch alle Hauptstädte aller Bundesländer.
Das weiß ja auch nicht jeder.
Nehmen wir mal die Hauptstädte der neuen Bundesländer. Brandenburg.
Wahrscheinlich Potsdam.
Richtig.
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern, Schwerin. Sachsen, wahrscheinlich Dresden.
Jetzt wird es hart. Thüringen.
Thüringen ist gar nicht so einfach. Ich dachte, ich lasse Sachsen-Anhalt mal raus.
Weiß ich auch nicht.
Thüringen.
Thüringen. Das ist eine unangenehme Sache. Jetzt kannst du keine Sau anhören.
Thüringen. das Land ohne Prominente. Erfurt.
Ah ja, okay. Und Sachsen-Anhalt?
Osbusch.
Das hätte ich wissen müssen, wusste ich aber nicht.
Wir wissen China. Wir wissen auch keiner, was die Hauptstadt von Hessen ist
und wir wissen auch keiner, was die Hauptstadt von Rheinland-Pfalz ist.
Hauptstadt von Hessen würde ich vermuten Frankfurt.
Tja.
Ist es aber nicht.
Wiesbaden.
Ja. In Rheinland-Pfalz?
Weiß ich nicht, da fahr ich nicht hin.
Auf der anderen Seite von der Brücke.
Wiesbaden auf der anderen Seite ist Mainz.
Mainz?
Ja. Wie singt und lacht. Das ist so ein Konglomerat.
Jetzt müssen wir alle Bundesländer machen. Was haben wir denn noch für Bundesländer?
Tja.
Ich hab jetzt die Wikipedia-Seite der neuen Bundesländer.
Kann ja alle sagen.
Schleswig-Holstein.
Kiel.
Hamburg.
Niedersachsen. Hannover.
Nordrhein-Westfalen. Düsseldorf.
Gibt es nicht mehr so viel. Baden-Württemberg.
Stuttgart.
München. Bayern. Bayern umgekehrt.
Das waren jetzt noch nicht alle 60.
Das ist jetzt nämlich die Frage. Haben wir schon was vergessen?
Und die Antwort ist ja. Wir haben das vergessen, was wir immer vergessen.
Saarland.
Unser Flächenmaß.
Saarbrücken.
Genau.
Und Bremen.
Ja, und Bremen. Ja, das ist auch so ein Flächenmaß, was mir zu selten angewendet wird.
Wo keiner weiß, was Sache ist. Es ist nicht so, dass sich daran jetzt irgendwas
festmacht, aber ist auf jeden Fall auch so eine Art Touring-Test,
um irgendwie Deutsche und Deutsche auseinanderzuhalten.
Jedenfalls,
wurden wir, hast du mich, also in der vorletzten Sendung habe ich irgendwie,
weiß ich nicht, Sachsen oder Thüringen oder so verwechselt.
Und dann hast du mich korrigiert und es war aber wieder falsch.
Alles durch anderem.
Wir haben zum Glück sehr ausführliches Feedback dazu.
Und XYZ sagt, sehr gut erkannt, die Verwechslung zieht sich mittlerweile durch
zwei Sendungen und sollte bitte korrigiert werden.
Hat er recht oder sie. Ein paar Fakten dazu.
Der Osten Deutschlands besteht nicht nur aus Sachsen, Okay, gut.
In Sachsen musste nach der Landtagswahl das Ergebnis der Sitzverteilung wegen
eines Fehlers in einer Berechnungssoftware korrigiert werden.
Quelle Mitteldeutscher Rundfunk.
In Thüringen verfügt die AfD
über eine Sperrminorität. Hat er auch nochmal eine Quelle mit angegeben.
Es ist wichtig, solche Tatsachen korrekt wiederzugeben. Habt Dank.
Und da hast du recht. Lord Sexy hatte das auch schon angemerkt.
Ja, ist richtig.
Die Thüringen-Sachsen-Konfusion ist jetzt final aufgeklärt worden. Ist doch gut.
Thüringen oder Sachsen, Hauptsache Zone.
Der muss sein, der muss sein.
Den müsste er jetzt.
Ja, der muss sein.
Den müsste er.
Rückmeldung zu Sprengstoffen. Genau. Ist auch ein explosives Thema, was wir hatten.
Florian R. schreibt uns zum Thema Detektion von Sprengstoffen.
Ich habe mich mal mit der Detektion von Sprengstoffen an Flughäfen beschäftigt.
Kurz eine Einschätzung. Erstens, die Menge ist sehr klein.
So klein, dass sie vermutlich nicht ausreicht, um zu einem Absturz zu führen.
Also wir hatten von diesen zwei Gramm gesprochen.
In den Pagern in Libanon. Die dann an die Hisboiler verteilt wurden.
Genau. Zweitens, es gibt zwei Arten von Detektoren. Einmal die Swaps,
damit wird über eine Oberfläche gewischt, zum Beispiel die Tastatur.
Was dahinter steht, ist die Annahme, dass bei der Arbeit mit Sprengstoff Spuren verteilt werden.
Da keiner der Pager-Besitzer mit diesem Sprengstoff hantiert hat,
sehe ich das nicht als besonders aussichtsreich, da Sprengstoffe zu erkennen.
Drittens, Gasdetektoren sammeln Dämpfe von Sprengstoffen analog zu den Spürhunden.
Die reagieren auf die Marker, aber auch auf den Sprengstoff.
Hier ist die Detektion nicht einfach, aber möglich. Ich vermute jedoch,
dass das Zeug auch gut eingepackt war und bei sauberem Arbeiten und passender
Verpackung haben sich diese Detektoren genau wie Hunde Schwierigkeiten.
Es hatte dann noch jemand weiter dazu kommentiert,
dass wahrscheinlich die Träger dieser Pager jetzt nicht unbedingt so einen Vielflieger-Status
genießen und des Weiteren,
selbst wenn sie fliegen,
was wollen die mit dem Pager im Ausland? Der kann ja nicht roamen.
Also der, sodass hier noch die Wahrscheinlichkeit dann relativ gering wäre, aber nicht gleich null.
Gleichzeitig kann man ja schon wieder darauf schätzen, äh, darauf setzen,
dass irgendjemand dann am Ende schon mit so einem Ding, ähm,
in der Tasche ins Flugzeug steigt.
Aber, ähm, genau, hier sagt er also User Unknown, äh.
Hisbollah-Kämpfer, insbesondere das Fußvolk, dürfte zu großen Teilen sehr viel seltener fliegen.
Inlandsflüge dürften ein sehr seltenes Phänomen sein. Pager dürften im Ausland wenig nützlich sein.
Und Pager dürften den Träger als Hisbollah-Mitglied verraten,
weswegen die Mitnahme auf Reisen womöglich von der Leitung strikt untersagt sein könnte.
Gegenanzeigen, selbst wenn es strikt verboten wäre, meine Spekulation,
würde im Laufe mehrerer Monate durchaus jemand mal sein Gerät aus Schusseligkeit
mit auf Reisen nehmen. B.
Sollen die Geräte ja auch zivil bei Rettungsdiensten etc.
hier und da noch im Einsatz sein, sind also vielleicht doch kein so guter Indikator
für einen Hisbola-Kämpfer.
Das Argument mit der Beimischung von Aromen überzeugt mich deutlich besser,
zumal der israelische Geheimdienst sicher ausreichend Möglichkeiten hat zu testen,
ob die Geräte mit dem Sprengstoff von Technik oder Hunden erschnüffelt werden kann.
das ist richtig also wenn die Israelis eins haben, dann ist das jede Möglichkeit an einem,
Flughafen irgendwas zu finden also das ist das haben die auf jeden Fall da brauchst
du dir keine Sorgen machen,
das war so bescheuert wir sind einmal da irgendwie von ich weiß nicht,
ob ich die Story sogar schon mal hier erzählt hatte bis auf der Unterhose, sag es,
erst, wir waren eine größere Reisegruppe,
und,
ich weiß,
ich erzähl die Story nochmal, wenn ich sowas schon erzählt habe Du hast es nicht erzählt.
Aber ich hab es zumindest vergessen aber das heißt natürlich auch nichts Wir
waren eine größere Reisegruppe.
Abflug Tel Aviv nach Berlin und waren alle technisch interessiert und hatten
auch entsprechend viel Elektronik im Rucksack und,
Kommt dann irgendwie an und noch bevor du unten bei diesem Check-in bist,
kam so eine Offizierin da zu uns und trennte unsere Gruppe.
Und dann wurden die Gruppenteile getrennt befragt.
Und dann haben die sich danach unterhalten, ob wir beide das gleiche erzählt haben.
Und ich hab dann irgendwie so, da unten, da wusste ich ja noch gar nicht,
ich bin gerade an der Tür. Ja, da dachte ich, das wäre dann danach vorbei und
hab dann gesagt, wäre jetzt wohl ein bisschen übertrieben oder so.
Und dann schrie die mich an in diesem Flughafen.
Der Check wäre ein bisschen übertrieben, meinst du?
Ja, und das war aber noch gar nicht der Check. Das war erstmal so,
wo dann ein Aufkleber auf deinen Pass kommt, rot-gelb oder grün oder so.
Ja, ja, ja, ja.
Und dann sagte ich so, ja meine Güte jetzt hier. Und dann sagte sie,
Sir, do you want a bomb on your airplane?
Und schrie irgendwie durch den Flughafen.
Und ich so, you can't say bomb at an airport.
Dann ging das weiter, dann haben die uns da angeschrien und weiß ich nicht was.
So und und dann irgendwie eingecheckt und stempelt. Achso, und dann hat sie
in meinen Pass geschaut und hatte gesehen, dass ich in Ägypten war.
Ja.
Da bist du auf jeden Fall schon mal in der Sonderbehandlung.
Ob ich das irgendwie witzig finde, hier die Feinde Israels zu besuchen.
Oh.
Ja, und da habe ich gesagt, ich habe die jetzt nicht als Feinde Israels besucht,
sondern weil man da irgendwie ganz gut tauchen kann.
Und okay, die war äußerst unangenehm. Und dann?
Absichtlich natürlich. Die wollen dich natürlich dann unter Stress setzen.
Klar, das ist ja überhaupt nicht gelungen. Ich habe ihr sofort angeschrieben.
So, pass auf. Und jetzt...
Das ist einige Zeit her. Und damals hatten wir, oder haben wir ja immer noch,
aber damals haben wir es noch sehr viel häufiger benutzt,
unser Equipment zum Abhören von 2G, also GSM-Verbindungen.
Und dieses Equipment bestand ja primär aus den Osmocom-Telefonen,
den Motorola C123, also so ganz basic 2G-Telefone, 90er Jahre Technologie.
Das sieht auf jeden Fall super spookig und verdächtig aus.
Nee, noch viel besser. Und mit einem so einem Telefon kannst du immer nur auf einen Kanal.
Oder beziehungsweise auf eine Hopping-Sequence. Wenn du aber sicher...
Alle Hopping-Sequences abklappern willst, dann brauchst du ganz viele Telefone. Wie viele?
Es wird noch viel besser.
Luca hatte eben so zwölf oder sechzehn. Aber diese Telefone waren außerdem,
die haben ja alle seriell gesprochen, deswegen hatten wir ein selber gelötetes PCB,
wo die Kabel rauskamen, in die Telefone gingen und dann mit USB in den Computer so.
Und jetzt pass auf, und damit das ordentlich transportiert werden konnte,
hatten wir auch noch Boxen, graue Boxen, in denen immer vier Telefone so angeordnet
waren und dann in der Mitte so ein PCB.
Und dann hattest du diese Boxen und dann hast du halt davon drei,
vier Stück und dann hast du, war das ausreichend reduziert auf USB-Ports,
dass du dann über USB mit den Dingern reden konntest.
Hattet ihr auch noch so ein Sieben-Segment-Countdown-Timer vorangebracht?
und offensichtlich so ein rotes und ein schwarzes Kabel, was so ein bisschen hervorsteht.
So und pass auf, wir gehen da hoch, da muss dann den Flughafen hoch und dann,
Rucksack, ne, und dann erster legt seinen Rucksack da aufs Band,
einmal alles auspacken, Kameraequipment, große Kameraequipment.
Und dann Luca, sein Rucksack da drauf, kriegt den wieder und ich wusste ja noch nicht, was da drin ist.
Und dieser Kontrolleur holt da irgendwie diese Handys,
diese aneinandergelöteten Handys mit den eigenen selbstgebastelten Platinen
und den USB-Kabeln und sagt so, was ist das?
Und Luca so.
Mobile-Phones, ja? Also hat er ja recht.
Oh, super.
Wofür brauchen sie so viele Mobiltelefone?
Zum Testen. Stimmte auch. Ja, stimmte.
Der Nachteil war, dass wir halt naja, die Sicherheitskonfiguration israelischer
Mobilfunknetze damit getestet haben und auch Schwachstellen gefunden hatten.
Die waren nämlich teilweise nicht verschlüsselt.
Und ihr habt euch nicht von dem Telekom-Operator einen Freifahrtschein für den
Flughafen ausstellen lassen?
Nein. Wir waren ja im Urlaub da. Das kommt nämlich als nächstes.
Im Urlaub macht er das.
So, was machen wir im Urlaub? So, dann kommt er und sagt, was testen Sie denn? Ja, Mobilfunknetze.
Okay, wofür brauchen Sie das? Und Luga so, for work. Und der Typ so,
I thought you were here on vacation.
Weil wir unten gesagt hatten, wir waren auf Urlaub.
Ja, ja.
Aber der Gag war, dann hat der dann nämlich mit seinem Mikrofasertuch da überall
drüber gewischt, hat das in diese Spektro-Analyse-Ding gegeben und dann so,
ja, alles klar, kannst du einen packen und dann durften wir damit fliegen.
Nachdem die uns da, die haben uns zwei Stunden angeschrien und am Ende haben
wir uns mit 16 Handys und selbst gelöteten Kabeln völlig problemlos in das Flugzeug gelassen.
Also ja, fand ich gut.
Und ihr musstet euch nicht bis auf die Unterhose ausziehen?
Nee.
Wow.
Also die wussten, wer so einen Quatsch macht, der hat auch nichts mehr im Bobbiss.
Mit einer falschen Antwort habe ich das geschafft.
Die wollten dann wirklich jedenfalls irgendwie meines Koffers auseinandernehmen.
Ja, nee, das hatten wir nicht.
Du gehabt.
Aber ja, es war auf jeden Fall ganz geil, wie der diese Handys sieht,
das ist auch eine Scheiße.
Ja, also das muss man denen schon lassen, also was so Security-Prozeduren und auch so,
Massenabfertigung betrifft, ich war ja in Israel noch so zur Corona-Zeit,
als es gerade so den ersten Dip gab und die gerade das Land aufgemacht haben,
da konnte man dann irgendwie mal hin, so für ein paar Monate genau,
in das Loch bin ich dann reingekommen und wie die dann dieses ganze Testing,
am Flughafen, weil es war dann Pflicht vor Ort, so, du musstest also vor Ort
einen Test machen, wie die das organisatorisch da gelöst haben,
wie man da durch die Hallen geschoben wurde, es war einfach so perfekt und so optimiert.
Nur Respekt dafür. Ganz grundsätzlich, also Flugreisen ab Israel machen überhaupt
gar keinen Spaß und wenn man da hinfliegt, will man auch nicht irgendwie mit
L.I. fliegen oder so, weil die,
ähnlich wie die Amerikaner natürlich den,
der Security in den jeweiligen Abflughäfen nicht trauen. Und dann nochmal ihre eigene aufbauen.
Das ist aber nicht nur, wenn du mit L.A. fliegst.
Ja, aber da dann nochmal ganz besonders, aber ja klar, das ist die ganze Zeit auf den Geist.
L.A. fliegst du, wenn du dir wirklich sicher sein willst.
Das ist sozusagen das Feature. Na gut, soviel zu dem Thema.
Ja, bleiben wir im kriminellen Bereich.
Das war ja sehr schön. Haben wir eigentlich alle Kommentare schon durch?
Hatten wir nicht drei? Ja, aber nur zwei.
Ich habe aus drei zwei gemacht.
Wir haben das gemeinsam beantwortet.
Böse Zungen behaupten, dass in diesem gesamten Bereich mit den Kryptotokens
gar nicht alles mit rechten Dingen zu tun.
Meinst du, dass da Schindluder unterwegs ist? Und das getrieben wird auch?
Und ja, sagen wir mal so, diese ganzen Leute, die Tokens ausgeben,
die sagen ja, ist wie eine Bank.
Insofern sollte man sich ja denken können, dass da nicht alles mit rechten Dingen zugeht.
Weil wenn man schon sagt, wir sind wie eine Bank, dann ja, also sie,
was sich da, was da häufig zur Vermutung steht, ist, dass da unter Umständen
Pump and Dump Schemes laufen,
also wo absichtlich ein Token hochgeschrien wird, hochgejubelt wird,
um ihn dann abzuverkaufen.
Außerdem machen sie das in Kombination mit solchen sogenannten Wash-Trades.
Das ist im Prinzip, also ein Wash-Trade ist ein Teil eines Pump-and-Dump-Schemes quasi,
wo du die ganze Zeit im Kreis handelst und dabei die Preise langsam hochziehst.
Wenn dann das Handelsvolumen eines Tokens zunimmt und auch gleichzeitig der
Preis, dann ist das natürlich eine hochinteressante Indikatorenkombination für Leute,
die Bock haben, schnell reich zu werden. Und.
Das FBI hat da jetzt 18 Personen und Organisationen, die an Betrügereien um
die Kryptowährungen beteiligt waren, angeklagt.
Und zu dem Zweck haben sie unter anderem einfach ihren eigenen Token gemacht.
Das ist schon ziemlich advanced.
Das ist schon ganz gut.
Falls ihr es noch nicht gemerkt habt, also diese Kryptowährungen,
wie sie immer hießen, werden nie als solche verwendet, also so gut wie nie,
sondern im Wesentlichen ist es hier einfach ein Anlagenhandel und es geht einfach darum,
mit Anlagen Geld zu verdienen und das funktioniert halt ganz gut,
wenn da immer so viel Betrieb drin ist.
Also wenn man in irgendeiner Form von außen dafür sorgt, dass irgendwie viel
Tradingvolumen ist und jetzt ist hier viel Interesse, dann springen dann entsprechend
die Glocken an und dann steigen halt auch mal schnell die Kurse.
Nur oft ist es halt kein wirkliches Nachfragephänomen, sondern eben nur das
Resultat von so einer Aktivität, die nur dazu hervorgerufen wird,
um das Interesse daran zu haben.
Und dann kaufen die Leute eben zu einem schon leicht überhöhten Preis in der
Erwartung, dass er noch höher steigt, tut er dann aber nicht.
Und der Token, den das FBI dafür verwendet hat, der heißt, oder die Chainer
auch immer, möge mir verziehen werden,
Saitama ist die FBI Currency,
darauf abgebildet wahrscheinlich Saita Reality und Saita Chain und dann gibt es noch andere,
Und Betroffene, Chains, Robo Inu, VZZN, Lillian Finance und Nextfund AI,
wo das FBI jetzt quasi weiß, wer da betrogen hat.
Aber wenn man sich jetzt mal hier bei CoinMarketCap anschaut,
was mit diesem Saitana passiert ist, seitdem das FBI das gesagt hat, ist er runtergegangen.
Wirklich?
Ja. Jetzt müsste man dem FBI natürlich sagen, also ganz ehrlich,
so das Dampf von Pump and Dump hat aber da jetzt das FBI vollzogen.
Das ist inzwischen eigentlich schon fast wieder, würde ich sagen,
da kann man schon wieder einsteigen.
Er wurde noch, also zu anderen Zeiten gab es dann höheres Handelsproblem.
Also wenn ich das richtig sehe, ist das Saitama nicht das, was von der FBI gelauncht wurde,
sondern um Manipulationen auf diesem Saitama-System zu finden,
haben sie ein Next Fund AI Projekt sozusagen gestartet,
mit dem sie ein eigenes Token auf der Ethereum Blockchain gestartet haben und
damit haben sie das dann irgendwie überwacht.
Oh, okay, dann habe ich das falsch.
Kurz zusammengefasst, das Detail ist an der Stelle auch nicht ganz so wichtig.
Seitama, Nexfand, Thüringen, Sachsen.
Das ist alles das Gleiche. Das Ding ist nur, also das ist ja die eigentliche Meldung.
Also, dass die, erstens, das FBI ist da schon richtig hinterher,
hier die ganzen kriminellen Aktivitäten, die es in diesem Bereich gibt und ich
glaube mir, da gibt es genug, das irgendwie zu fangen und sie,
gehen auch schon so weit, dass sie da eben selber aktiv in diesen Handel mit
reingehen und dafür sorgen, dass Leute ihnen sozusagen auf den Leim gehen und
daran können sie dann eben entsprechende Aktivitäten messen.
Und das ist wirklich schon ziemlich krass, finde ich, weil das bedeutet vor
allem, das FBI hat Leute, die was von der Materie verstehen.
Ja, das wird in Deutschland so nicht passieren, Tim.
Aber kann ich mir auch nur sehr schwer vorstellen. Also ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass es Leute gibt, die was von der Materie verstehen, aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass die entsprechendes Backing und entsprechendes Funding haben,
um eine größere Aktion zu launchen.
Aber vielleicht werden wir ja auch eines Besseren belehrt und sind da alle viel
fitter und toller drauf, als wir das so denken.
Ich halte das allerdings generell für eine gute Idee, in diesem Segment die
Augen offen zu halten, weil da wird auf jeden Fall eine Menge Kohle von links
nach rechts gezogen, um sie aus den Taschen von Leuten zu ziehen,
die denken, das wäre immer noch eine tolle Sache.
Aber du hast recht, genau. Sie haben Nextfund.ai gegründet und haben sich von
anderen Leuten dann erklären lassen, wie macht man denn so schöne Pump-and-Dump-Skinys?
Und die haben dann gesagt, ja, pass auf, das machen wir hier so und so und so.
Ja, hast du aufgepasst.
Hast du aufgepasst? Ich schalte schon immer ab, wenn du...
Ja, das geht mir nicht anders.
Big News, da hat jemand betrunken.
Ich schaue ab und zu mal so auf web3isgoinggreat.com und es ist einfach eine
permanente Geräuschkulisse von Betrügereien,
von, wie heißt das nochmal gleich, wenn man den Teppich, Ruckpulls,
wenn irgendwelche neuen Systeme aufgebaut werden, die Leute schmeißen ihre Kohle
rein und dann verschwindet auf einmal dieses Unternehmen so komplett so,
ja danke für euer Geld wir sind dann mal weg und so, das findet halt einfach täglich statt.
Wir haben in der letzten Sendung ja über das Überwachungspaket gesprochen und
da haben sich ja dann, meine Güte,
dann haben sich irgendwie ein paar Grüne gesagt, sie wollen da nicht mehr mitmachen,
also nicht bei den Grünen, sondern bei dem Überwachungspaket ausnahmsweise mal nur.
Und jetzt haben aber die stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden gesagt, ja, ja,
die Koalition ist sich jetzt einig und wir werden das jetzt am kommenden Mittwoch
im Innenausschuss des Bundestages einbringen und dann wollen wir das im Bundestag
am liebsten schon irgendwie in der darauffolgenden Sitzung so ungefähr im Bundestag
beschließen, in der darauf kommenden Sitzungswoche.
und dann kann das eigentlich schon am 18. Oktober in den Bundesrat.
Also ja, jetzt wollen sie es doch, also,
ich verstehe es wirklich nicht, wir haben in der letzten Sendung schon genug
drüber gesprochen, aber ich verstehe irgendwie nicht, wie die sich das,
was dieser Quatsch soll.
Also in dieser, vor allem.
Was versuchen sie damit zu retten? Also sich?
Naja, also eine Idee ist ja, oder eine Perspektive, die man so haben kann,
ist warum wählen Leute eigentlich diejenigen, die ihnen die ganze Zeit Angst machen?
So, weil sie davon ausgehen, dass diese Leute wenigstens das Problem erkannt
haben und sich bemühen werden, es zu lösen.
Ja.
Und wenn man davon ausgeht, dass das irgendwie, dass das für Menschen eine Rolle
spielt, dann könnte man daraus ableiten, dass man den anderen nur zu vorkommen
muss, das Problem zu lösen.
Jetzt ist aber natürlich, wenn das Problem eigentlich gar nicht gibt,
dann wirst du das ja auch nicht lösen.
Das scheint das Problem zu sein, was die Ampel hier nicht so ganz verstanden hat.
Aber ja, es ist katastrophal. Solingen, also Solingen, neue Bundesländer.
Aber,
Entschuldigen? Neue Bundesländer?
Äh, alte Bundesländer, Entschuldigung, natürlich, meine Güte.
Oh, jetzt war mein Witz ja total. Alte Bundesländer, Nordrhein-Westfalen ist
das wahrscheinlich sogar, oder?
Ich vermute, ja. Last time I checked.
Keine Landeshauptstadt?
Das ist sogar ganz in der Nähe von Düsseldorf. Mehr in Nordrhein-Westfalen geht gar nicht.
Ich habe eine andere Vorstellung davon, wo Nordrhein-Westfalen ist.
Ich denke, du kennst dich da aus in Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Eben, aber Düsseldorf steht ja nicht für Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Das ist nur die Hauptstadt.
Ja, das ist ja.
Wie kann denn das passieren? Wie kann denn Düsseldorf, wieso ist die so unpopulär
eigentlich? Was ist überhaupt mit Düsseldorf?
Düsseldorf?
Warum haben denn alle in Nordrhein-Westfalen ein Problem mit Düsseldorf?
Kein Problem.
Sondern?
Ist einfach, ja, ich weiß nicht. Also, es hat ja kein Problem mit Düsseldorf.
Das einzige Problem, was ich mit Düsseldorf habe, ist, wenn ich sage,
ich komme aus dem Ruhrgebiet, dass die Leute sagen, Düsseldorf, ne?
Und dann muss man sagen, Düsseldorf ist halt nicht Ruhrgebiet.
Es ist nicht Ruhrgebiet.
Ja, aber es heißt ja nicht Nordrhein-Ruhrgebiet, sondern Nordrhein-Westfalen.
Es heißt aber auch Nordrhein-Rhein-Westfalen. Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Düsseldorf ist, es ist halt nicht Ruhrgebiet.
Ich habe überhaupt gar kein Problem mit Düsseldorf. Ich bin gerne in Düsseldorf.
Ich war dieses Jahr schon in Düsseldorf.
Wirklich?
Bin jedes Jahr in Düsseldorf.
Ah, echt?
Ja.
Ich weiß ja nicht, Hannover kennt man gar keine Ahnung. In Düsseldorf kann man.
Also, Düsseldorf, guck mal, die Stadt, die muss ja herausragend schön sein.
Also bei einer Stadt, die ein derartiges Bier braut, ja, und trotzdem bleiben die Leute da.
Da kannst du dir ungefähr vorstellen, was das für eine prächtige,
wunderschöne Stadt ist.
Okay, also, Problem ist Altbier oder was?
Altbier ist...
Ich weiß, also ich habe nichts gegen Düsseldorf.
Okay, gut. Wir müssen das auch nicht weiter vertiefen. Ich dachte nur,
du kannst mich da ein bisschen mehr aufklären, wo das Problem eigentlich ist mit Düsseldorf.
Es gibt kein Problem. Hast du mit einem Kölner geredet oder was?
Nein, ich höre das halt immer nur so. Was habe ich mit Nordrhein-Westfalen zu tun?
Ich komme da nicht her und ich habe da keine Erfahrung mit. Ich war noch nicht
mal auf dem Karneval in Köln. Nicht einmal.
Und in Düsseldorf?
Auch nicht.
Natürlich war ich auf dem Karneval in Düsseldorf.
War noch nie auf dem Karneval.
Und in Köln. Ja, klar.
Und? Nimmt man da irgendwas fürs Leben mit?
Kommt drauf an, wie viel du trinkst.
Wie gesagt, die Region bleibt mir ein Rätsel, aber ich habe auch nicht unbedingt ein Problem damit.
Jetzt weder mit Köln noch mit Düsseldorf.
Wenn du zu wenig trinkst, trinkst du nichts mit.
Wenn du zu viel trinkst.
Trinkst du nichts mit.
Hauptsache Union gewinnt.
Spielt Fortuna Düsseldorf.
Sind wir noch beim Thema eigentlich jetzt?
Okay, gut.
Chatkontrolle. Ja, machen wir nächstes Thema. Nächstes Thema.
Irgendwie kommen wir heute immer so ein bisschen vom Thema ab.
Wir müssen darüber hinwegtholen, dass eigentlich nichts Interessantes zu erzählen
gibt. Das ist ein Problem.
Das Thema macht einen Schmank aus unserem Leben. Das interessiert euch.
Vor zehn Jahren am Flughafen. Wie habe ich dir schon erzählt?
Das sind doch keine schmutzige Details aus unserem Lebenskanal.
Das ist das, was euch interessiert.
So, ähm.
Jetkontrolle.
Genau, also Ungarn wollte das ja unbedingt durchprügeln. Markus hat es ja in
der letzten Sendung noch erzählt.
Aber die Sperrminorität hat gehalten,
mehrere Länder und deswegen wurde das Thema bei dem EU-Ministertreffen nur am
Rande behandelt und es besteht weiterhin keine Einigkeit.
Also hat auch Ungarn mit seinem Anlauf das jetzt nicht geschafft,
die Chatkontrolle durchzusetzen.
Wobei ich mich da jetzt wirklich frage, ob das sozusagen eher eine Opposition
gegen Ungarn ist, weil die es dann wieder übertreiben wollten und weil die generell
daran nicht so besonders beliebt sind oder ob das Thema halt einfach keine Einigung
erfährt. Wir wissen es nicht.
Mein Traum wäre, ich würde eigentlich immer hoffen, dass es um inhaltliche Auseinandersetzungen geht.
Aber Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt, aber sie stirbt.
Hast du die Reden von diesen grünen Europa-Parlamentsabgeordneten gehört?
Ich weiß nicht, wann ich, also die einzigen Ausschnitte aus Parlamentsreden,
die höre ich im Podcast Parlamentsrevue.
Ich kann mir das nicht angucken. Ich gucke auch keine Talkshow,
Anne Will hatte gar keine Talkshow mehr.
ich kann also eine Parlamentsrede Ja.
Die willst du vielleicht nochmal nachhören, weil da haben sich zwei Grüne wirklich
hervorgetan, während Orban wirklich neben ihnen saß als Präsident,
haben die da halt eine Rede gehalten und haben auf ihn eingeredet und haben
gesagt, sie sind einfach ein fucking Diktator und sie haben ja in Europa nichts
zu suchen und euch schmeißen wir raus und ihr seid korrupt und das war wirklich volles,
Programm Richtig gut. Ich suche nochmal die Links raus.
Aber ging es da um Chatkontrolle?
Nee.
Da sind wir schon wieder vom Thema abgewogen.
Ja, aber es hat was mit Orban und damit mit Ungarn zu tun.
Okay.
Also ich wollte damit ja nur ausdrücken, die Stimmung ist nicht besonders gut,
was Orban betrifft, nachvollziehbarerweise.
Und die Stimmung ist so schlecht, dass sie sich also wirklich ernsthaft drei
Meter neben ihm irgendwie ans Mikrofon stellen und dann minutenlang auf ihn einreden.
Man soll ja auch nicht hinter dem Rücken über die Leute reden.
Finde ich gut. Das stimmt.
Weiter im Text. Karlsruhe hat mal wieder was entschieden. Ja.
Keine Landeshauptstadt.
Ne, das stimmt. Aber auch wichtig. In Deutschland ist alles, jede Stadt hat was.
Entweder du bist Landeshauptstadt oder irgendwas kriegst du immer ab vom Kuchen.
Wie jede Stadt.
Ja, jede Stadt hat irgendwie eine, Also jede nennenswert große Stadt hat irgendwas
abbekommen von unserem föderalen Gesamtsystem.
Und Karlsruhe dürfen halt die Richter hochholen.
Generalbundesanwalt und Bundesverfassungsgericht. Und KIT.
Ja, ist jetzt nicht so bundesregelmäßig, aber hat auf jeden Fall auch Bedeutung.
Ja.
Das stimmt.
Aber jede Stadt hat was abbekommen.
Ja, irgendein Institut, irgendeine Behörde, irgendein Gericht,
irgendwas Wichtiges ist überall zu finden.
Ist jetzt nicht alles in Berlin. Auch Leipzig. Was ist denn da?
Weiß ich nicht, keine Ahnung. Irgendwas ist da auf jeden Fall. Irgendwas ist immer.
Das ist so.
Kongress.
Auch nicht mehr.
Naja, auf jeden Fall haben sie die Köppe zusammengehalten, weil die Gesellschaft
für Freiheitsrechte, GFF, geklagt hat.
Zusammen mit so diversen Beschwerdeführern.
Gegen das BKA-Gesetz, was ja ein weiteres Mal reformiert wurde,
nachdem Karlsruhe schon mehr als einmal, oder was, nur einmal, ich weiß nicht.
Also auch schon ein weiteres Mal vorher gesagt hat, Leute, so wie ihr das macht, geht das nicht.
Das müssen wir jetzt mal ein bisschen einschränken.
Und es ging halt wieder darum, dass diese ganzen Überwachungsbefugnisse,
die in dieses PKA-Gesetz reingeschrieben wurden, dass die so nicht verfassungsgemäß sind.
Wer hätte es gedacht, Linus? Wer hätte es gedacht?
Auf jeden Fall nicht das Bundesverwaltungsgericht. Das ist nämlich nicht in
Karlsruhe, sondern in Leipzig.
Ah ja, ich musste kurz gucken, was ist.
Meine These stimmt.
Das Bundesverwaltungsgericht ist eines
der fünf obersten Bundesgerichte in Deutschland und es ist in Leipzig.
Okay, und jetzt wo du vom Thema wieder abgelenkt hast, führ mal wieder zurück
und erklär mir mal, was die dann jetzt beschlossen haben.
Das Bundesverwaltungsgericht in Leipzig nicht zu verwechseln mit dem Bundesverfassungsgericht,
bei dem gegen das BKA-Gesetz in Karlsruhe wiederum alte Bundesländer vorgegangen wurde.
Insbesondere hat man sich damit zwei Aspekten der BKA-Gesetznovelle,
die noch aus der rot-rot-schwarz-roten Regierung stammten.
Die sogenannte Große Koalition, die Älteren erinnern sich.
GroKo 2.
Und da wurde entschieden, dass man quasi die ganzen Datenbanken zusammenführt
zu einer großen, einmal alles Datenbank, der Inpol.
Und da soll so ungefähr einfach einmal alles rein.
Und dann weiterhin wurde in
diesem BKA-Gesetz geregelt, dass das BKA Kontaktpersonen überwachen darf.
Was ist eine Kontaktperson? Eine Kontaktperson wird nicht selber einer Straftat bezichtigt,
steht aber im Kontakt mit einer Person, die dem Durchführen oder der Planung
einer Straftat bezichtigt wird.
und das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts in Karlsruhe,
Nicht in Leipzig und auch nicht in Erfurt, weil Erfurt ist in Thüringen.
Ich lasse es.
Thüringen. Was gibt es noch?
Wo? In Thüringen oder in Erfurt?
Eigentlich nichts. So und dann das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat also jetzt geurteilt,
die Überwachungsbefugnisse des BKA gegenüber bloßen Kontaktpersonen sind verfassungswidrig,
weil sie das Recht auf informationelle Selbstbestimmung dieser Personen verletzen.
Also kann es nicht einfach irgendjemand überwachen, nur weil er Kontaktperson ist.
Und für die Speicherung und Nutzung von Informationen in der polizeilichen Datenbank in Pol,
sagt Karlsruhe, naja, da müsst ihr wenigstens mal klare Grenzen definieren,
was quasi eine Speicherungsschwelle ist,
damit es da reinkommt.
Sonst erwarten wir hier eine massiv anwachsende Bevorratung von personenbezogenen
Daten und deswegen hätten wir gerne mal irgendwie eine Speicherungsschwelle,
damit jetzt nicht jeder Fußballfan oder was in dieser Inpol-Datenbank landet.
Genau, Fußballfans sind auch ein gutes Thema. Einer der Beschwerdeführerinnen,
fünft an der Zahl glaube ich in diesem Fall, war auch aus dem Fußballumfeld
und war selbst davon betroffen, muss man ja sein, sonst kann man da auch nicht
entsprechend vorstellig werden.
Und das ist halt, es gibt ja diese Datenbank, Gewaltdäter Sport,
die sozusagen so eine Untertabelle ist in diesem System und dort stehen eine
ganze Menge Leute drin und da stehen aber auch eine ganze Menge Leute drin,
die nicht wirklich jetzt als Gewalttäter in irgendeiner Form schon gemeldet sind,
sondern das sind halt Leute, die irgendwie nur mit dabei waren.
Da ist dann irgendwie ein kompletter Bus auf der Autobahn rausgezogen worden
mit Fans und irgendwie einer hatte ein Edding dabei und dann wurde sofort Schmierereien
unterstellt und dann landen aber dann irgendwie alle,
die im Bus sitzen, landen dann halt auf einmal auch in der Datenbank.
Da kann man sich denken, ja okay, gut, in der Datenbank, was ist das schon das Problem?
Das Problem ist, dass es dann eben auch häufiger zu weiteren Untersuchungen,
Aufhaltungen führt, dann werden also Leute, dann werden Stadionverbote ausgesprochen
oder Leute dürfen irgendwie nicht ins Ausland reisen, um an irgendeinem Spiel,
Auswärtsspiel ihrer Mannschaft teilzunehmen etc.
pp. Und das wird schon von den ganzen Fanhilfen seit Jahren verurteilt, zu Recht.
Und sieht so aus, als ob jetzt dieser Widerspruch, der hier in Karlsruhe ausgesprochen
wurde, vom Bundesverfassungsgericht, auch diesen Teil betreffen kann.
Das stimmt ja sogar wirklich der war in einem Werder Fanbus unterwegs und bei
einem Zwischenhalt in Göttingen soll jemand mit einem Edding irgendwas hinterlassen
haben und deswegen wurden,
dann alle in dem Bus ich dachte das wäre gerade ein Beispiel was dem tatsächlich
passiert und in Konsequenz durfte er nicht zum Champions League Spiel nach Entschredde,
weil die Bundespolizei ihm die Ausreise untersagt hat.
Und das ist halt, das ist jetzt ein Fall, aber ich habe schon von vielen solchen
Fällen gehört und das ist halt einfach ein Problem.
Ich meine, es ist ohnehin diese ganze Wahrnehmung von Fußballfans als Gewalttäter,
als potenzielle Gewalttäter, also nicht, dass da nicht auch was passiert,
aber dass das jetzt ein überbordendes Problem ist, das kann man so,
glaube ich, nicht mehr festhalten.
Es gibt ja auch in der Öffentlichkeit so eine Wahrnehmung, die ja noch aus den
90ern stammt, als dieser Hooliganismus um sich griff.
Da war es aber halt jetzt mitnichten so, dass das jetzt primär vom Fußball aus
ging, sondern es war einfach nur, dass diese Hooligan,
dieser Trend, es war ja fast schon wie so ein Jugendsport, dass man sich eben trifft zum Schlagen.
Und die haben sich dann halt einfach in Veranstaltungen untergemischt,
wo halt sowieso schon viele Leute sind.
Und dann wurde es eben im Rahmen von Fußballspielen und drumherum oft ausgetragen
und fiel dann wiederum auf den Fußball zurück.
Ja.
Die haben, also wenn die sich da treffen und sich gegenseitig die ganze Zeit
auf die Fresse hauen, kann man ja eigentlich davon ausgehen,
dass sich das Problem früher oder später von alleine löst, oder?
Ja gut, aber hat sich dann auch.
Oder? Jetzt regen sich trotzdem dann wieder alle auf. Ja, es hat sich insofern
gelöst, als das von den Fußballvereinen wiederum durch Fanarbeit da gegengehalten wurde.
Dass halt die Leute aus den Fanszenen rausgehalten wurden, dass die Fanszenen
sich da selber auch gereinigt haben von diesen Leuten und einfach dafür gesorgt
haben, dass sie wieder ihr Fußballding machen können.
Aber in dem Zuge sind halt immer wieder diese ganzen begleitenden Maßnahmen
hochgefahren worden und es gibt halt generell immer so diese Wahrnehmung,
oh Gott, jetzt Fußballspiel, es wird wieder alles ganz schlimm,
wir brauchen ganz viel Polizei.
Bis hin zu der Forderung, dass eben jetzt die von der Polizei und dann sozusagen
vom Kontrollapparat selbst aufgestellten Regeln mit,
wenn Veranstaltungen die und die Größe und Dimensionen hat und das trifft dann
bei Fußballspielen oft zu,
dann muss auch so und so viel Polizei da sein.
dann stehen da irgendwie Herrscharen an Polizeiwannen rum und bohren sich in
der Nase nicht, dass die nicht auch manchmal,
sinnvoll sein können, dass die da sind aber es führt eigentlich eher dazu,
dass genau diese Präsenz dann zu Problemen führt einerseits und andererseits,
kommen dann eben Bundesländer wie Bremen zum Beispiel dann auch auf die Idee
sagen, das ist aber ganz schön teuer mit diesen vielen Polizisten,
die wir da hinfahren müssen, auf eure Veranstaltung könnt ihr da nicht mal für bezahlen.
Und dann war es schon so ein bisschen an dem Punkt, wo die Leute für ihre Überwachung
auch noch selber bezahlen.
Das ist dann irgendwie auch ein schwieriges Feld.
Jetzt weißt du, was Überwachungskapitalismus wirklich heißt.
Den Witz kenne ich schon aus meinem Lieblingsfilm Brasil aus den 80ern.
Ja, dass die Leute einfach irgendwie mehr für ihre Überwachung bezahlen sollten.
Das ist da literally ein Joke in dem Film.
Kann ich wirklich sehr empfehlen.
Den Film Den kann man sehr empfehlen, ich kann mich nur tatsächlich an die Szene
nicht erinnern, dass wir mehr bezahlen müssen Alright, also wir können wieder
mit dem Edding ins Stadion,
Endlich,
Hoffnung Und vielleicht können wir demnächst sogar vermummt da wieder hin Meinst du?
Ja, mir gefällt das auch nicht, dass ich da die ganze Zeit mein Klargesicht zeigen muss.
Ja, also man muss ja tatsächlich mal drüber nachdenken mit dieser biometrischen
Überwachung, die uns früher oder später ins Haus steht,
dass wir in Deutschland auch noch ausgerechnet bei den demokratischen Versammlungen,
bei den Demonstrationen ein Vermummungsverbot haben.
Und es ist relativ interessant,
also wenn du mal bei einer etwas aufgeheizteren Demonstration bist,
wenn da jemand auf die Idee kommt, die Kapuze zu tief ins Gesicht zu ziehen
oder gar sich zu vermummen,
dann geht das relativ schnell, dass die Person wirklich sofort aus dem Verkehr
gezogen wird von der Polizei und angegriffen wird und das hat dann empfindliche
Strafen hinter zur Folge,
weil irgendwie man eben bei einer Demonstration da so eine alte,
ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das beschreiben soll, so eine archaische,
zeig dein Gesicht, wenn du dafür einstehst oder so, was man ja vielleicht erstmal
intuitiv nachvollziehen kann.
so eine Überlegung, dass man sagt, wir wollen, wenn die Leute schon demonstrieren,
dann sollen sie dafür auch mit ihrem Gesicht stehen können. Ähm.
Jetzt kannst du dir aber überlegen, mach mal irgendwie ein CSD in Bautzen oder
so oder mach mal eine Demonstration da in der Nähe oder zu einem Thema,
das irgendwie gerade von Rechtsradikalen besetzt wird,
dann wird dieses Vermummungsverbot natürlich auch verwendet,
um Menschen dort zu filmen.
Und dann bist du, wenn du irgendwie mal auf dem falschen Foto bist oder so,
unter Umständen relativ schnell mit langfristigen Problemen ausgestattet.
Und gilt natürlich auch andersrum, dass jetzt, sagen wir mal,
eine der Möglichkeiten, warum die Neonazi-Szene so bekannt ist,
ist natürlich auch, dass man sie, wenn sie auf die Straße geht,
halt einfach fotografieren kann und sich damit auseinandersetzt, wer da wer ist. aber.
Man sollte das jetzt nicht abhängig davon machen, wer jetzt die Guten und wer
die Bösen sind, sondern was eine Regel für das Zusammenleben ist und ich muss
irgendwie sagen das Vermummungsverbot,
tja also ich glaube es hat natürlich, es hat einen ganz guten oder hat potenziell
eine Wirkung dabei unter Umständen aus einer Demonstration heraus stattfindende Straftaten,
einzudämmen oder zu verhindern, ungefähr zweimal im Jahr oder so,
vielleicht auch dreimal, aber für viele, viele andere Demonstrationen und damit
eigentlich für den größeren Teil der Masse an Demonstrationen,
ist das eigentlich eine nicht nachvollziehbare und unter Umständen auch nicht zumutbare Auflage.
Ja, es ist schwierig. Also ich kenne da keine belastbaren Zahlen,
an denen man das irgendwie festmachen könnte.
Aber das war ja immer das Argument, dass quasi von einer Vermummung Putin,
dass dadurch sozusagen von vornherein auf einmal Straftaten auf Demos möglich
sind und das muss ja verhindert werden.
Und diese Straftaten sind ja dann häufig Auseinandersetzungen mit der Polizei gewesen.
Die sich der Demonstration in den Weg stellt oder sonst was.
Wo auch immer dann sozusagen, also da wird es beide Seiten gegeben haben.
Da wird es Übergriffe auf die Polizei gegeben haben, die nicht gerechtfertigt waren.
Genauso wie wir das auch immer wieder leider beobachten müssen,
dass es Übergriffe von der Polizei gibt, die nicht gerechtfertigt sind.
Die Polizei darf sich aber vermumpen.
Ja, die Polizei sich auch ganz gut vermummt und sich auch immer trefflich gegen
eine Nummernkennzeichen von Mitarbeitern wert.
Gewährt hat.
Gewährt hat, das hat eine Weile gedauert, aber das ist natürlich dann,
gilt das im Prinzip ja für alle.
Jetzt gibt es aber natürlich eine neue Entwicklung, Gesichter,
Suchmaschinen und überhaupt die Diskussion biometrischer Überwachung in diesen
Sicherheits- und Überwachungspaketen der Bundesregierung,
wo man sich ernster fragen muss, naja, wenn das jetzt noch alles kommt,
wenn hier demnächst dann die Stadt mit intelligenter Videotechnik ausgestattet ist…,
Muss er denn? Also ist dann ein Vermummungsverbot noch zeitgemäß?
Ja, also was das ja bedeutet im Prinzip ist,
man beobachtet mit hochauflösenden Kameras einen Demonstrationsblock und macht,
der Computer analysiert in Echtzeit diese Bilder, das ist ja mittlerweile keine
Zukunftsmusik mehr, sondern das haben wir ja jetzt hier auch schon mehrfach durchdiskutiert.
Wir erinnern mal vielleicht kurz an diesen Fall der aufgegriffenen Terroristin,
die durch eine Websuche aufgefunden wurde.
Nicht ursprünglich durch die Polizei, sondern in dem Fall eben durch so ein
Journalistenteam, die selber sehr überrascht waren über ihre Ergebnisse,
aber es gibt ja diese ganzen Datenbanken und,
es gibt in zunehmendem Maße eben jetzt diese Bestrebung, solche Datenbanken
eben auch aufzubauen und dann eben auch automatisiert anzuwenden.
Im Prinzip sind solche Systeme nicht nur vorstellbar, sondern man kann sich
das heute zusammenbauen. Das ist machbar.
Die Technik dafür ist da.
Das heißt, man hält eine Kamera auf einen Demonstrationszug durch und kann es
im Prinzip in Echtzeit die Namen durchrollen sehen.
Weil es ist halt insbesondere auf Video nochmal sehr viel besser erkennbar,
weil du eben mehrere Positionen siehst, etc.
eines Gesichtes über die Zeit und da muss man sich mittlerweile überhaupt gar
keine Illusionen mehr machen.
Gesichtserkennung ist halt machbar und damit sozusagen eine Echtzeit vollständige
digitale Identitätserfassung im öffentlichen Raum.
Mit einer politischen Agenda verbunden, weil das ist nun mal das,
was so eine Demonstration üblicherweise repräsentiert.
Ja und das ist doch, also dann muss man doch wirklich sagen, dass sich hier die,
die Außenbedingungen oder die technologischen Bedingungen dann doch durchaus
verändert haben und da muss man in meinen Augen durchaus mal die Frage stellen
Und das tun jetzt auch Leute, nämlich Amnesty International,
die GFF und die Humanistische Union sagen, wie wäre das denn,
wenn man das jetzt mal sein lässt.
Und wir reden hier nicht von Kleinigkeiten, bis zu ein Jahr Haft für Vermummungen
bei einer Demonstration.
Allein das Mitführen von Vermummungsutensilien kann eine Geldbuße von bis zu
500 Euro nach sich ziehen.
Vermummungsutensilien. Also sowas wie eine Skimaske zum Beispiel.
Ja, oder eine FFP2-Maske. Das war ja auch ein großes Thema.
Das war ja tatsächlich Thema bei diesen Corona-Demos.
Na gut, die, die demonstriert haben, die waren ja jetzt nicht diejenigen,
die unbedingt eine Maske tragen wollten.
Aber man kann auch eine Gegendemo machen, wo dann alle eine Maske tragen.
Kommt immer drauf an, welche Demo das war.
Aus Sicherheitsgründen.
Ich finde es auf jeden Fall mal nicht schlecht, das zu diskutieren.
Der Vollständigkeit halber sei aber auch erwähnt, dass dann beispielsweise so
Dinge da, wo Videoüberwachung ist, dann teilweise argumentiert wird oder erzwungen
wird, dass die dann ausgeschaltet wird, wenn eine Demonstration stattfindet.
man kann es jetzt nicht überprüfen. Erstens kann es jetzt nicht überprüfen und
zweitens, ja gut, dann schalten sie die Kameras aus, aber du kannst ja heute
sowieso bei jeder Demonstration irgendwie
Polizisten mit so einem riesigen Selfie-Stick, die da eh alles filmen.
Und erstaunlicherweise immer, wenn da so Polizeigewalt stattfindet,
dann passiert auf einmal auf der anderen Reihenseite was ganz Spannendes,
was sie auf einmal filmen.
Apropos Interessantes auf der anderen Rheinseite,
das Antwortverhalten bei Telegram hat sich verändert und zwar auf,
dass das Antwortverhalten bei Bestandsdatenauskünften.
Pavel Durov war ja jetzt einige Zeit in Frankreich, ist er eigentlich schon raus wieder?
Nö, also der ist nicht mehr in Haft, aber der ist meines Wissens noch in Frankreich
oder ich hab da vielleicht was übersehen, ich schau noch mal kurz nach.
Also ich glaube der ist auf freiem Fuß, aber wartet noch auf ein Verfahren,
wie auch immer du suchst das mal raus,
jedenfalls war es bisher immer so, dass wenn du bei wenn jetzt so Nachrichtendienste
oder Polizei bei Telegram nach den Bestandsdaten eines Accounts gefragt haben,
bekamen sie keine nennenswerte Antwort.
Bestandsdaten sind nicht die Verkehrsdaten, aber beispielsweise so etwas wie
die E-Mail-Adresse oder die Telefonnummer, auf die ein Account kommt.
Angemeldet wurde. Und wenn du jetzt bei Facebook eine Bestandsdatenauskunft
machst, dann sagt Facebook, okay,
was haben wir zu diesem Account hier, was weiß ich, das ist die E-Mail-Adresse
Tim at hast du nicht gesehen und der wohnt in Berlin.
Und wenn eine solche Anfrage bei Telegram einging, hat Telegram die üblicherweise
abgelehnt und gesagt, das machen wir nicht.
Und jetzt gibt es einen Transparency-Report von Telegram und der weist aus,
dass im Jahr 2024 insgesamt 53 Anfragen aus Deutschlands zu IP-Adressen und
oder Telefonnummern beantwortet worden seien.
Und davon seien insgesamt 115 Nutzer betroffen gewesen.
Und die deutschen Sicherheitskreise bestätigen das und dass Bestandsdaten und
bei unmittelbarer Gefahr für Leib und Leben auch Emergency Disclosure Requests beantwortet werden.
Ja, und auch die Anfragen deutscher Behörden etwa zu religiösem Extremismus
und Terrorismus seien zeitnah beantwortet worden.
Interessant, also haben sie
ihn jetzt vielleicht doch, hat er seine Gesinnung gewechselt, der Pavel.
Außerdem laufen ja gegen ihn in Frankreich Ermittlungen wegen mehrerer mutmaßlicher
Straftaten und hat jetzt gesagt, er will sich darum bemühen,
dass die illegalen Inhalte, die es bei Telegram gibt,
nicht auch noch beworben werden.
Er hat zum Beispiel in einem Telegram-Post auf seinem Channel gesagt,
Telegram ist ja schon sehr gut, man kann sehr gut nach Gruppen suchen zu bestimmten
Inhalten und dass das natürlich quasi…,
Also wenn du da jetzt so eine Terroristengruppe hast, dann hast du über Telegram
nicht nur die Kommunikation in dieser Gruppe, sondern auch noch,
dass andere dich finden können.
Und das wollen sie jetzt ein bisschen einschränken. Ja.
Ja, also Paul, Pavel Durow ist, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ich sehe keine andere
Nachricht diesbezüglich, nach wie vor frei auf Kaution, also er befindet sich in Frankreich und ja,
dem scheinen sie also schon relativ klar deutlich gemacht zu haben,
dass es so wie bisher nicht so weiterlaufen kann.
Also wenn jetzt sogar schon die Deutschen auf einmal Antwort bekommen,
dann hat das einfach schon mal Gehör gefunden.
Klar, der fürchtet natürlich jetzt um seine Haut.
Die Truppe, die ihn da wohl für die Verhaftung gesorgt hat,
das ist halt auch eine dedizierte Cybercrime-Unit, die sogenannte Unalko-Einheit
und die steckt halt auch schon so bei anderen Aktionen wie gegen dieses Encro-Chat,
über das wir schon mal berichtet haben dahinter und so weiter.
Also die sind da, glaube ich, relativ klar.
Also da wäre ich gerne mal Mäuschen gewesen bei dieser Verhandlung so,
dem scheinen sie dann doch relativ klar gemacht zu haben, dass sie einfach überhaupt
keinen Bock auf seine Nummer haben, um es mal einfach zu formulieren.
Fragt sich, warum Nancy Faeser das vorher nicht gelungen ist.
Ja. Die hat halt gefragt, ob sie bitte, bitte vielleicht, ob er nicht mal was schicken könnte.
Ja, ist halt einfach, die französische Methode ist da, glaube ich,
ein bisschen expliziter.
Okay.
They don't fuck around much.
Ich hab da immer so den Film Nikita irgendwie vor meinen Augen.
Ich weiß auch nicht warum.
Den ich auch sehr empfehlen kann. Zweite Filmempfehlung jetzt schon. In einer Sendung.
Nur noch Filme empfohlen. Also Brasil wird hier aber doch sehr oft empfohlen.
Wirklich? Ich glaub, das ist das erste Mal, dass wir den empfohlen haben.
Nein, das hat schon hundertmal gesungen. Dieses Lied von Brasil und so. Naja, ist egal.
Siehste? So, wir machen Sendung zu Ende, bevor du jetzt den nächsten Lied singst.
Also mit dem Singen.
Filme kannst du empfehlen, Tim, aber singen...
Ist nicht, meinst du? Pass nicht zu unserem Style, meinst du?
Ne, passt einfach nicht zu deiner Radio-Gesicht, äh, Stimme.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen hart. Jetzt muss ich ein bisschen weinen.
Ne, passt schon. Leute, kurze Sendung von uns und...
Ihr hört uns sehr bald schon wieder.
Genau, ja, wir haben schon wieder Wir haben schon wieder was vor.
Mal gucken. Mal gucken, ob das passiert.
Genau, was dabei rauskommt. Insofern entlassen wir euch. Kurze Sinn.
Könnt ihr auch mal einen anderen Podcast hören?
Nö, lassen wir die anderen. Gebt mal in die frische Luft, macht mal irgendwas
anderes. Nicht immer nur Podcast hören. Hört mal schön weiter unseren Podcast.
Vielleicht gehen die Leute ja auch mit unserem Podcast in die frische Luft.
Ist der Gedanke schon mal gekommen?
Ich glaube, die sitzen zu Hause und schreiben mit.
Meinst du? Achso, Aufsatz.
So würde ich das erwarten. Also nein, nicht Aufsatz.
Hefte raus, Logbuch-Netzpolitik ist wieder erschienen.
Die wichtigsten so ein paar Stichpunkte, dass man halt sprechfähig ist.
Man mitreden kann. Auf der Party meinst du jetzt in der Küche.
Ja, wir wollten sonst die Nerds sein auf der Party. Also ich war immer in der Küche.
Auf einer Party ist man immer in der Küche, weil in der Küche sind die interessanten
Gespräche. Ich weiß nicht, warum das so ist.
Ob das mit der potenziellen Versorgung zu tun hat, aber ich weiß nicht,
die Küche hat glaube ich irgendwie erzeugt irgendwie eine andere soziale Reaktion.
Deswegen hat wahrscheinlich auch jeder eine in seiner Wohnung.
Das ist der einzige Grund.
Ja.
Falls man eine Party macht, damit die Leute auch was zu diskutieren haben.
Gut, wir entlassen euch und wünschen euch schöne Folgetage. Nach dem Konsum dieser Sendung.
So ist es. Machen wir das. Bis bald.